Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
chapter
narration number 41 authored by Noi.
He mentions a narration. This is our
third day discussing this narration. In
order to understand it properly we
had to take some introduction to it.
[Silence]
on the authority of Abdah
who narrates that we came to complain to
the messenger of Allah sall.aii Wasam.
This was in the days before hijra in
Mecca during the during the
torture and persecution that the
companions and our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam were enduring.
He says we came to complain to the
messenger of Allah sall.ai Wasam
of this persecution
whilst he was sitting on a cloak that he
had spread out for himself under the
shade of the Kaa.
And so we said to him, "Will you not
seek victory for us over our enemies
from Allah? Will you not make dua for us
that he alleviate this difficulty?
He said,
"Those
nations that have come before you,
the followers of the prophets and
messengers of the previous nations were
subject to such persecution
that a man amongst them might be taken
and placed in a ditch that would be dug
for
And
and so
those nations that came before you, they
endured such persecution
and punishment at the hands of their
enemies that a ditch may be dug for one
of them.
And he would be placed in this ditch and
they would bring out a saw and place it
at the top of his head and continue to
saw until he was made into two halves.
While others amongst them might be taken
and rad with rakes of iron that would
separate their
skin
and separate their flesh from their
bones.
All of these methods of torture and
persecution would not repel or hinder
them from their religion and their
adherence
to following their respective
prophets.
[Silence]
He said, "I swear by Allah.
Allah will
eventually give victory to this religion
and it will spread and it will have its
day
to the point that a rider and a traveler
might even be able to travel through the
barren lands between
in Yemen toot
also in Yemen.
or which is ine two
interpretations of the narration.
The only thing that a traveler of such
distances will fear is Allah
and the wolf over his flock. Meaning
that this religion will
spread and its followers will be so
numerous and this day will be forgotten
and this hardship will be but a
distant memory to the point that a
person can travel anywhere in the most
dangerous of
places and be in the most secluded of
situ. situations and environments and
fear no one but Allah and the wolf over
his flock. Meaning they will not fear
bandits. They will not fear tribal wars.
They will not fear opportunists. Why
is that? Is that because there is a
police officer for every citizen? Is
that because we will police them with
cameras and listening devices and AI to
crawl itself into every crevice of a
human being's privacy, leaving him
completely
without dignity in order to watch and
make sure that everybody is obeying the
law. or else the black ring lords will
show up with their sticks and handcuffs.
No, that's not how you police a people.
Overpolicing only makes
crime go underground and only
intensifies it because human beings have
a tendency of rebellion and they have a
tendency of revolution and they have a
tendency of defiance.
And so
this is not what will change people and
make humanity better. Some humans
watching other humans. No, what will
make humanity better is when people
become true slaves and servants to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He says that this
will eventually come to pass.
Yet you all are being hasty. We have to
go through this in order to get to that.
So, we have to be patient for Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's victory.
Notice how they didn't say,
you know, we're just sitting here. We're
not doing anything. We should be
planning. We should be doing this. We
should be doing that. , you know, we
should be no, we should be learning
and perfecting our worship of Allah.
Victory comes from Allah. and it's taken
away by Allah. Subhanahu wa'ta'ala. So
seek it from Allah. This narration has
[Arabic recitation]